pour l'instant ils ne sont qu'une petite
dizaine de salariés installée dans un
coin des locaux et l'heure est à la
formation dans tous les cas tu as ton
père l'asc dahra besoin de diffuser
pendant une année sur le bon coin
parmi les employés candy elle a quitté
un précédent emploi pour rejoindre le
célèbre site d'annoncés un grand groupe
si une entreprise jeune dynamique avec
des belles perspectives devant elle et
ce qui m'intéresse aussi c'est que ses
proches de chez moi
ces futurs commerciaux seront chargés de
vendre auprès des entreprises des
emplacements pour leurs offres d'emploi
en bourgogne le bon coin dispose déjà
d'un site basé à montceau les mines où
une centaine de salariés s'occupent déjà
des professionnels aux plus de 500 mille
professionnels qui diffuse sur leboncoin
soit pour de la notoriété à travers la
publicité soit pour vendre à travers les
petites annonces ou encore pour le
recrutement
depuis sa création en 2006 l'entreprise
est en expansion
près de 28 millions de visiteurs se
connecte par mois sur le site
de quoi pousser les élus à tout faire
pour attirer l'entreprise sur leur
territoire à mâcon elle est installée à
la cité de l'entreprise
mais c'est provisoire elle devrait
bientôt déménager en centre ville
l'opération coeur de ville avec
l'installation d'entreprises tertiaires
en plein centre ville
je sais qu'il y aura d'autres qui vont
suivre cet exemple c'était la volonté du
conseil municipal que d'arriver à mettre
des entreprises tertiaires pour ramener
de la population ramené de l'activité en
plein centre ville
à terme le banc quoi prévoit d'embaucher
près d'une centaine de personnes sur le
site mâconnais